hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the community
a textbook six
Aristotle will discuss several qualities
of mind besides the intellectual virtues
they are important for attaining truth
particularly in practical matters that
is attaining the the end that work we
need these are you might say adjuncts to
to the virtue of prudence and as we can
see they got they all sort of fit into
it in different ways we've already done
want a video specifically on excellence
of deliberation abulia
there's two others that we need to talk
about understanding or Sinise's and
consideration or good ol main these also
play important roles and Aristotle
derives very interesting conclusion in
thinking about all of these so let's
look first at understanding he uses two
words here he says you can you can call
us an ASIS when people talk about those
in a sea ah that's the same thing you
know good understanding literally is
used in Asya
some basis is just understanding
understanding by itself is a good thing
he specifies not only that is it not the
same thing as knowledge or opinion but
it's also not
same thing as prudence why not well
prudence in a person has he says issues
commands it tells you what is to be done
or what is not to be done you know to do
something other than that or not to do
that particular thing he in a given
situation and it's very important for
figuring out you know the context and
the particulars that one is working with
because that you know in virtue ethics
there aren't hard and fast rules that
apply everywhere to everything we need
prudence to help us figure that sort of
stuff up understanding is very similar
to prudence but as he says it makes
judgments it's to Tk this is the word
that we get critic from tweet community
case that we chase means judge so could
etk means like a judge and what does it
actually make judgments about it doesn't
make judgments in the same way and that
prudence itself issues commands it does
so specifically in relation to what
other people who are quite often giving
us moral guidance or leading us into
various temptations telling us what we
ought to do what other people saying
about matters that prudence bears upon
so you see that it has to do it the same
range of things as prudence but it's
approaching it from a different manner
the prudential person is considering ok
what is it actually good for me or what
is good for this other person that i
might want to get some advice to the
person of understanding is able to take
in you know what
hopefully the prudent person is saying
perhaps not pretty and judging perhaps
the person actually says yeah i'm going
to listen to that advice because that
person has screwed their life up or they
don't seem to know what they're actually
talking about that would in fact be
understanding in the sense of the
aristotle is discussing here another
very important quality is consideration
or know may you know may can mean
several different things in greek it's
used in the writer nature type of
actions which are sayings that that
people you know sort of like one-liners
a bird in the hand is worth with two of
the bush that's an example of you know
main consideration as Aristotle talks
about it in the Nicomachean ethics
doesn't have to do with sort of every
sort of thing it has to do with what he
calls the the equitable and it has to do
with we can call it forgiveness if we
want but it's a little bit more
restrictive than that you might think of
it as overlooking or letting something
slide Aristotle in fact thinks that
there are there quite a few things that
you shouldn't forgive or a lot of that
slide so it's not a sound like you know
tolerating everything but he thinks that
it's important to allow oneself to give
people the benefit of the doubt when
when it's actually appropriate and what
tells you when it's appropriate is
consideration organ oming he goes on he
says it's not just a matter of being
considerate to everybody says this is
indicated by saying the equitable man is
considered is especially considered for
others that is forgiving and that it's
equitable to show consideration for
others in certain cases but
consideration for others is that
consideration which judges rightly what
is equitable judging right of the
meaning judging what is truly equitable
not what somebody just happens to make a
case for or what appears to be equitable
but what is genuinely equitable in that
context in that situation where the
rules get to be bent and where one ought
to enforce them now talking about these
sorts of other key qualities Aristotle a
little bit later in the Nicomachean
ethics is going to say that you know
this is why we think that these are
natural gifts quite often and we use
them Kenaston anima Slee with with each
other this is also why he says the
unapproved
surgeons and opinions the things that
that people say and opine you know
pronounce forth of experienced and older
elderly or prudent people not everybody
just those three classes experienced
older and prudent this is why we think
that those are just as much deserving of
attention as those which they support by
proof the word therefore proof is aqua
Texas and when I translated that here he
has is not rigorously demonstrated so
you know when somebody who actually has
quite a lot of experience in an area so
maybe we call it expert by the way the
word expert comes from the word for
experience that's why we have you know
similar expert experience right the
Xfinity in lap the the person who has
put in the time to have the amount of
experience can tell you things about hey
you shouldn't do that they don't have to
give you a whole rigorous demonstration
in order for it to be right to listen to
them and in order for them to be correct
about that they may in fact be wrong but
odds are they're probably more onto what
is right than the average person is
older people Aristotle tends to think
that older people hopefully have
gathered more experience and have done
some more reflection of course you
wouldn't want to listen to one who you
think is imprudent like you know when we
talk about here understanding told you
this guy doesn't know what he's talking
about don't pay attention to or if they
manage to totally screw up their life
unless they're talking about how bad it
is to screw up a life maybe they're not
a participant in the conversation
anymore prudent people prudent people
are also ones who we want to listen to
so all of these kind of work in together
in making prudence do its full work they
make it more flexible they allow us to
take
the the views of other people were their
relevance where they can conduce to our
own good or the good others who we we
need to advise and ideally they'll
function and harmony with each other
within the person's soul or personality
or mind